september 30 1974. it's just past
midnight and chilean general carlos
gonzalez and his wife sophia are
returning home after a night out in
buenos aires argentina
the general gets out of his car to open
their garage door he takes a few steps
and then boom his car explodes and the
general is blasted 13 feet in the air
while his wife still in the car dies
instantly
general carlos and his wife had fled
chile in 1973 just a few days after the
cia had launched a bloody coup to
overthrow chile's democratically elected
presidents
one year later on october 6 1975 during
a late afternoon in rome italy bernardo
lane a former leader of chile's
christian democratic party is taking a
quiet walk with his wife suddenly a man
appears from the shadows and opened
fires on bernardo and his wife
luckily the couple survives but
bernardo's wife is left permanently
disabled due to her injuries
another year later on september 21 1976
and orlando la terrier a former chilean
politician and his american colleague
ronnie moffett are driving through
washington dc they're just passing
through sheridan circle when orlando's
car explodes
the two of them die almost instantly
in the 10 years between 1973 and 1983
the world experienced hundreds of
mysterious assassinations and
disappearances and all the victims were
connected to south american politics and
power politicians were gunned down in
public activists and students were
kidnapped on the streets never to be
heard from again children vanished from
their homes re-emerging years later in a
different country with different names
different passports and completely
different identities
in just a decade hundreds of cases were
opened at police stations around the
world but almost none of them would ever
be solved
and it all started with the
disappearance of two american citizens
in chile this is frank terugi a 24 year
old student and journalist at the
university of chile in the capital of
santiago and this is charles horman a
journalist and filmmaker who was living
in chile with his wife in the early 70s
in the days after the 1973 cia back coup
in chile both frank and charles
disappeared their friends and family
desperately tried to get ahold of them
but no one seemed to know anything about
where they could be
the truth was both frank and charles
have been kidnapped by soldiers
answering to a man named augusto
pinochet the us friendly president of
chile that was installed by the cia
after overthrowing chile's democratic
president with the help of the cia
general pinochet has started rounding up
anyone who supported the old presidents
and started dumping them in chile's
national stadium
here the prisoners most of them being
students politicians officials and
activists were interrogated tortured and
often killed
and frank and charles were unfortunately
part of that group rounded up by chilean
soldiers the two men had been taken to
the stadium frank the student was seen
beaten electrocuted and eventually
killed with a machine gun
a few days earlier charles hormann had
met a similar fates his body was buried
in the stadium wall
now obviously the american government
immediately started an investigation
right two american citizens have been
murdered by a foreign dictator the cia
must have started putting together a
special forces unit to retaliate right
when the news leaked right no
america never launched any
investigations and never asked any
questions and never placed any pressure
on the chilean government to have anyone
face justice because it knew exactly
what had happened to the two americans
in fact it was the us military
intelligence who had given the chilean
soldiers the two men's locations
the us government had handed two
american citizens journalists to general
pinochet's killers on a silver platter
why because they were leftists socialist
loving leftists
and in the 1970s the cia was funding and
supporting a secret war against
communism in south america and even
american journalists who supported
communism were seen as the enemy
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime in my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
you just have to be following me at jake
trend and you're automatically entered a
few of you have won already watch out
for fake accounts i will never message
you asking for money and this is
operation condor
[Music]
it all started on september 11 1973.
that was the day a military dictator
general augusto pinochet carried out a
coup against chile's democratically
elected president with the help of the
cia
salvador allende had been elected
president just three years earlier and
because of his socialist views he had
decided to nationalize chile's very
valuable copper industry which basically
meant he wanted to put chile's copper
mines under the government's control the
only problem was that chile's copper
mining industry had been monopolized by
american businesses for years and these
american businesses didn't like the idea
of losing all their money equipment and
future revenue all because of one guy so
they expressed their concerns to their
connections in washington they told
president richard nixon that allende was
definitely a communist that communists
had infiltrated his regime that he was
helping fidel castro that if the u.s
didn't act now he was going to let the
soviet union take control of all of
south america in other words they played
the domino effect card and it worked
like a charm
with everyone scared that chile was
about to turn red and hand over all
those juicy copper mines to the russians
it didn't take long for the cia to get
involved for three years they did
everything they could to get allende out
and finally in september 1973 their plan
worked the chilean military overthrew
the democratic government
[Music]
president allende died in the process
and general augusto pinochet claimed the
throne and he would rule chile with an
iron fist
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and one of his first acts as president
rounding up the leftists activists and
all his enemies and putting them in the
ground in just the first three weeks
after the coup more than 1 000 chilean
civilians were executed and more than 14
000 were rounded up and
questioned
[Music]
[Music]
in the first year of pinochet's rule he
rounded up another 130 000 people many
of them ended up dead
general pinocchio knew that to stay in
control of chile he would have to
consolidate power and root out anyone
who could stand up against him he just
had one problem he couldn't get to all
of them
you see in the weeks following the coup
thousands of activists politicians and
opposition leaders had fled to
neighboring countries like argentina
bolivia and even further out to brazil
colombia and uruguay and in these
countries his enemies were basically
untouchable the governments of these
other countries had no reason to arrest
or kill them and from the safety of
their new homes all of those activists
and politicians can make life hell for
pinochet they could hold rallies give
interviews or even organize a rebellion
from just across the border it was
unacceptable
something would have to be done to
silence the runaways once and for all
and so operation condor was born you see
chile wasn't the only country being led
by a military dictator uruguay brazil
paraguay and even argentina were all
under the control of their own murderous
power-hungry military dictators and they
had all discovered the same problem with
their questioning and killing campaigns
the people they were after would all
just hop the border and keep riling up
anti-government support from the safety
of their new homes
but
what if all these dictators could agree
to work together what if they could
collaborate to spy on arrest and
extradite the communist activists their
neighbors were looking for
now if a chilean activist had fled to
argentina he could be arrested in
argentina and sent right back to chile
to be questioned
better yet the argentinian military
could even do the questioning for them
and if an argentinian activist jumped
over the border into chile well the
chilean government would happily return
the favor it was the agreement of every
military dictator's dreams
little did the south american dictators
know that the cia had noticed their
little arrangement and was about to make
its own charitable contribution
[Music]
all the craziness that's been happening
with the economy recently really shows
you that you can't rely on anyone but
yourself not your employer and certainly
not your governments that is why it's
more important than ever to be building
up your side hustle so that you can
eventually turn that into your main
source of income and the simplest side
hustle for most people to start off with
is turning a skill you already have into
a business by becoming a freelancer
maybe that's offering translation
services if you know two languages or
becoming a freelance writer or graphic
designer or web designer or maybe even
as a virtual assistant there's a lot of
money to be made the problem is actually
getting a freelancing side hustle off
the ground is really hard and
overwhelming how much do i charge how do
i get my first clients the list just
goes on and on but lucky for you that is
where appsumo comes in appsumo was
created by my good friend noah kagan
who's a serial entrepreneur in employee
number 30 at facebook and one of the
ebooks appsumo offers is called
freelancing and consulting as a side
hustle and you gotta check it out and
don't worry this ebook usually costs 29
but for my viewers you're gonna get this
for only one dollar and it gives you
everything you need to know to actually
make money on the side with freelancing
you're gonna get blueprints for setting
your rates so you can charge what you're
worth you're gonna get nine proven
techniques for landing your first client
and all the best practices for sending
invoices avoiding sketchy clients
managing your time and so many more
shortcuts so if you've been waiting for
a cent to start making money for
yourself this is it but the thing is
this insane 1 deal is only available for
the first 100 people who click the link
below and sign up so pause the video and
click the link below to be one of the
first 100 people to get this freelancing
ebook for just one dollar thanks to
appsumo for sponsoring this video
[Music]
is
operation condor was supposed to be a
transnational intelligence operation
targeting marxist subversives
translation a bunch of countries were
going to work together to take out
communists but here's the thing just
like the cia had done to countless
foreign presidents they wanted to
overthrow the members of operation
condor also had a pretty liberal
definition of communism
accuse the government of murdering
people communist write a paper on how
the military dictatorship is ruining the
economy communist join a rally for free
and democratic elections surprise
surprise another communist anyone who
didn't bow down to the south american
dictators of operation condor were
immediately classified as communists
that way arresting torturing or
murdering them could kinda be justified
considering the whole world was fighting
a war against communism anyway
and unsurprisingly the us rather liked
the idea of exterminating communists
without all the hassle of investigations
trials and all that jury of their peers
nonsense
operation condor was offering them
instant gratification see a communist
take him out so once the cia picked up
on operation condor and its goals
instead of blowing the operation wide
open warning the people they were
targeting or in some way trying to stop
all the murdering and torturing they
thought what can we do to help
back then almost all of the us's
policies against communism focused on
the domino effect the theory that if
just one country on any continent or
region fell to communism all its
neighbors would eventually turn
communists too
the only issue was america had gone to
war in vietnam based on the dominant
theory and it had not gone well with the
american public
so if the u.s government wanted to stop
the spread of communism this time in
south america they were gonna have to do
it in secret and what better way to stop
communism from spending in south america
than by supporting operation condor that
way if any of it ever came out the blame
wouldn't fall in the cia it would fall
on the murderous dictators it was a
win-win situation for both the cia and
the members of operation condor and once
those two groups started working
together they became nearly unstoppable
[Music]
by the late 1970s operation condor was
in full swing never before had a group
of south american countries work so well
together than when they were rounding up
and questioning their enemies
they were communicating sharing
intelligence and even conducting joint
training operations together with their
troops even the cia was impressed with
that level of cooperation but then they
ran into another issue an operation of
this size would need a lot of support
they would need a solid communication
system between countries so they could
quickly share information on people to
arrest and kill but they would also need
training
after years of unrest none of the member
countries of operation condor really had
the skills or the facilities to train
death squads assassins and interrogators
after all if they were gonna do all this
without getting caught they were gonna
need more than your everyday guerrilla
fighter with no real training
and that's where the cia came in the cia
happily offered the operation condor
members their very best communication
gear that happened to be wiretapped this
would allow each condor country to
communicate quickly and easily with the
others while also giving the cia
unlimited access to the messages they
were sending so not only did the cia
know exactly how many people were being
eliminated they knew who was going to be
targeted next and gladly stood back and
did nothing
but that's not all because the
militaries of all the condor countries
still needed training and who better to
teach them how to interrogate kidnap and
kill than the u.s military and so the
school of assassins was born its actual
name was the school of the americas and
it was first opened under that name in
panama in 1963.
basically the school of the americas was
supposed to be a joint training base
where america's allies in south america
could come for high-level military
training from the american army but
that's not what really happened
in reality south american soldiers from
condor countries were being trained in
enhanced interrogation and how to
blackmail kidnap drug and execute their
targets
in fact some of south america's most
violent dictators death squad members
and assassins graduated from the school
of americas in the 70s and early 80s and
the methods the condor soldiers ended up
using were merciless but we can't go
into depth here or else this video will
get demonetized which is why you should
pause the video and click the join
button below for our more controversial
documentaries we can't release to the
public
[Music]
nothing the operation condor countries
did to their enemies was too gruesome or
too cruel for america to support these
were noble capitalist dictators ridding
the earth of vile communist scum
obviously the ends totally justified the
means this included things involving
helicopters and pregnant women that
again we can't go into much detail about
operation condor was probably one of the
worst examples of america's tunnel
vision when it came to communism
anything anything was justified as long
as the communists were suffering for it
and by the late 70s the group of condor
member countries had grown with the
addition of brazil ecuador and peru
and as time went by condor started
looking more like the purge rather than
an american-backed intelligence
operation
in 1980 the condor members supported a
military coup in bolivia as a result
general luis mesa took power using money
he received from bolivian traffickers of
a certain white powder as a thank you
for operation condor support he opened
bolivia up to condor soldiers and turned
a blind eye as thousands of people were
being questioned and eliminated as a
result
in argentina operation condor's missions
were even more brutal under the military
dictatorship of jorge videla and with 50
million dollars in financial assistance
from the american government argentina
waged its dirty war against the new
president's opponents
in the seven years that the war lasted
more than 30 000 people were killed or
disappeared forever
in total operation condor resulted in
the deaths of at least 60 000 people
that we know of the actual number could
be way higher but none of this mattered
to america or the cia they were just
happy to see every last south american
socialist leftist and communist running
for their lives
u.s secretary of state henry kissinger
even congratulated argentina for wiping
out communist terrorists and even
attended the 1978 soccer world cup in
argentina as president videla's personal
guest
it looked like operation condor was
unstoppable but then with one small
mistake one tiny misstep argentina
bumped over the domino that would bring
the entire operation to its knees
[Music]
you see all that killing and kidnapping
operation condor was happily carrying
out was starting to have a very negative
effect on the member country's economies
the rich and well-educated were fleeing
to north america and europe to escape
becoming the next victim and those who
were too poor to run were getting sick
and tired of living in fear and no one
felt the pressure of a popular uprising
more than argentina in a last-ditch
effort to keep the masses at bay
president videla invaded the falkland
islands he hoped that by reclaiming land
most argentinians believed to belong to
argentina he could drum up a little more
support among the people he was planning
to eliminate the falkland islands had
been a british colony for 90 years when
argentina invaded unsurprisingly when it
came to a war between britain's powerful
navy and argentina's guerrilla fighters
the british won
humiliated by his easy defeat and
threatened by thousands of protesters in
the streets jorge videla was forced to
allow elections to take place in 1983.
1983 became the year that brought
democracy back to argentina but jorge
videla's fall also meant the end of
operation condor inspired by what
happened in argentina thousands of
people across south america started
calling for free elections america and
its puppet dictators had to admit defeat
1983 marked the end of operation condor
and in the end these south american
dictators were finally forced to face
the consequences of their actions
most of the big players in operation
condor ended up spending decades in jail
but as you can guess the american
politicians and intelligence officials
that approved and supported operation
condor continued to enjoy their comfy
lives never facing any consequences
operation condor taught america and the
cia something very important as long as
you have a good reason for doing
something you can get away with anything
all the cia and us government had to do
to justify supporting operation condor
was point out that the member countries
were fighting communists
and suddenly murder kidnapping and
enhanced interrogation were all
perfectly okay
so when the time came around for
america's next global offensive the war
on terror they used the exact same
tactic
between 2001 and 2009 hundreds if not
thousands of arabic men and women some
suspected terrorists and some completely
innocent were enhanced interrogated by
the cia
while america was accusing countries
like syria north korea and iraq of human
rights violations the cia enhanced
interrogated prisoners in secret prisons
or black sites all over the world
without ever charging them with a crime
and the stuff that happened in these
black sites makes operation condor look
like a kid's birthday party that's how
evil it got the blacksight program was
one of the darkest periods in america's
history but no school or university will
ever tell you the full story which is
why we've made a full-length documentary
on exactly how the cia's black site
started how the cia used them and why
it's probably still happening around the
world today
but here's the thing youtube is really
good at demonetizing sensitive or
controversial content which would
definitely include a video about
enhanced interrogation so instead we've
released it as a private documentary
available only to members of this
channel all you have to do to get access
to this documentary right now as well as
all the videos we've already published
on the cia's mind control program the
roots of middle eastern terror and even
a deep dive on our friend every jepstein
is to click that join button below
people pay tens of thousands of dollars
every year to universities only to leave
not knowing anything about how the world
really works but by becoming a member
you get all of this priceless
information for just five dollars a
month and we promise you it's way more
entertaining than university lectures
plus there's also a refund policy unlike
most youtube memberships so if you join
in you don't think it's worth it email
us within your first month of joining
and we will personally refund you for
your first month after your first month
there is no refund so scroll down and
click that join button below right now
back at it again with anchoring the cia
if you're new here my name is jake and
this is one of the biggest channels on
youtube for documentaries on money power
war and crime so if you enjoyed this one
we make multiple videos just like this
for free every single week so you should
subscribe with the button below and
click that join button too if you watch
shorter versions of these videos you can
follow me on facebook and if you want a
chance to win a thousand dollars you can
follow me on instagram not sure how much
longer we're going to be running that
giveaway so get in while you can but
that is going to wrap it up as always
stay dangerous out there and i will see
you guys
[Music]
you